the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
now today we're continuing with this
last unit unit five continued the
informal title of this unit is dealing
with with infinity that's really the
extra little piece that we're putting in
to our discussions of things like limits
and integrals to start out with today
I'd like to recall for you l'hopital's
rule and in keeping with the spirit here
we're just going to do the infinity
divided by infinity case i stated this a
little differently last time and i want
to state it again
today just to make clear what the
hypotheses are and what the conclusion
is we start out with really three
hypotheses with two of them are kind of
obvious the three hypotheses are that f
of X tends to infinity G of X tends to
infinity that's what it means to be in
this infinity over infinity case and
then the last assumption is that F prime
of X divided by G prime of X tends to a
limit L and this is all as X tends to
some a some limit a alright and then the
conclusion is that f of X divided by G
of X also tends to L as X goes to a
all right now so that's the way it is so
it's it's three limits but presumably
these are obvious and this one is
exactly what we were going to check
anyway
gives us gives us this this one limit
all right so that's the statement and
then the other little interesting point
here which is consistent with this idea
of dealing with infinity is that a
equals plus or minus infinity and L
equals plus or minus infinity are okay
that is the numbers capital L the limit
capital L and the number a can also be
infinite now in recitation yesterday you
should have discussed something about
rates of growth which follow from what I
said in lecture last time and also maybe
from some more detailed discussions that
you had in recitation and I'm going to
introduce a notation to compare
functions namely we say that f of X is a
lot less than G of X if so this means
that the limit as it goes to infinity
this tends to zero all right as X goes
to infinity this would be X goes to
infinity all right so this is a notation
a new notation for us f is a lot less
than G and it's meant to be read only
asymptotically it's only in the limit as
X goes to infinity that this happens and
implicitly here I'm always assuming that
these are positive quantities F&G you're
positive what you saw in recitation was
that you can make a systematic
comparison of all the standard functions
that we know about for example the log
function goes to infinity but a lot more
slowly than X to a power a lot more
slowly than
e to the X a lot more slowly than say e
to the x squared all right so this one
is slow this one is moderate and this
one is fast and this one is very fast
going to infinity
all right tends to infinity and this is
of course as X goes to infinity all of
them go to infinity but it but quite
different rates and analogous to this
and today we're going to be doing this
needing to do this quite a bit is rates
of decay which are more or less the
opposite of rates of growth so rates of
decay or rates at which things tend to
zero so the rate of decay and for that
I'm just going to take reciprocals of
these numbers so 1 over log X tends to 0
but rather slowly it's much bigger than
1 over X to the power P oh I didn't
mention that this exponent P is meant to
be positive that's a convention that I
using without saying I should have told
you that so I think X to the 1/2 xx to
the first power x squared they're all in
this sort of moderate intermediate range
and then that in turn is goes to 0 but
much more slowly than 1 over e to the X
also known as e to the minus X and that
in turn well this guy here goes to 0
incredibly fast all right e to the minus
x squared vanishes really really fast
all right so this is a review of the
l'hopital's rule what we said last time
in the application of it which is two
rates of growth and tells us what these
rates of growth are
today I want to talk about improper
integrals and improper integrals we've
already really seen one or two of them
on your exercises and we mention them a
little bit briefly I'm just going to go
through them more carefully more
systematically now and we want to get
just exactly what's going on with these
rates of decay and their relationship
with improper integrals so I need to to
understand it for you to understand on
the spectrum of the range of functions
like this which ones are suitable for
integration as X goes to infinity well
let's start out with the definition the
integral from a to infinity of f of X DX
is by definition the limit as n goes to
infinity of the ordinary definite
integral up to some fixed finite level
that's the definition and there's a word
that we use here which is that we say
the integral so this is terminology for
it converges if the limit exists and
diverges if not well these are the key
words for today so here's the issue that
will be going to be addressing which is
whether the limit exists or not in other
words whether the integral converges or
diverges
these notions have a geometric analog
which you should always be thinking of
at the same time in the back of your
head I'll draw a picture of the function
here it's starting out at a and maybe
it's going down like this and it's
interpreting it geometrically this would
only work if f is positive then the
convergent case is the case where the
area is finite so the total area is
finite under this under this curve and
the other case is the total area is
infinite now I claim that both of these
things are possible although this thing
goes on forever right if you if you stop
it at once stage and then of course it's
a finite number but as you go further
and further and further there's more and
more and more area and there are two
possibilities either as you go all the
way out here to infinity the total that
you get is adds up to a finite total or
else maybe there's infinitely much for
instance if it's a straight line going
across there's clearly infinitely much
area underneath
all right so we need to do a bunch of
examples and that's really our main job
for the day and and to make sure that we
know exactly what to expect in all cases
the first example is the integral from 0
to infinity of e to the minus K X DX
where K is going to be some positive
number some positive constant this is
like the most fundamental by far of the
definite integrals now in order to
improper integrals in order to handle
this the thing that I need to do is to
check the integral from 0 to up to n
each of the minus KX DX and since this
is an easy integral to evaluate we're
going to do it it's minus 1 over K e to
the minus KX that's the antiderivative
evaluated at 0 and N and that if I plug
in these values is minus 1 over K e to
the minus K capital n minus now if I
evaluate it at 0 I get a minus 1 over K
times e to the 0 all right so there's
the answer and now we have to think
about what happens as n goes to infinity
so as n goes to infinity what's
happening is the the second term here
stays unchanged but the first term is
each of some negative power and the
exponent is getting larger and larger
that's because K is positive here you've
definitely got to pay attention even
though I'm doing this with general
variables here you've got to pay
attention to signs of things because
otherwise you'll always get the wrong
answer so you have to pay very close
attention here so this is if you like e
to the minus infinity in the limit which
is 0 and so in the limit this thing
tends to
tends to zero and this thing is just
equal to one over K and so all told the
answer is 1 over K and that's it now
we're going to abbreviate this a little
bit this thought process you're going to
have to go through every single time you
do this but after a while you also get
good enough at it that you can make it a
little bit less cluttered so let me show
you a shorthand for the same for this
for this same calculation namely I write
0 to infinity each of the minus K X DX
and that's equal to minus 1 over K each
of the minus K X 0 to infinity all right
uh-huh
that was cute not small enough however
ok well alright so so here we are we
have the same calculation as we had
before but now we're thinking really in
our minds that this infinity is some
very very enormous number we're going to
plug it in and you can either do this in
your head or not you say minus 1 over K
e to the minus infinity here's where
I've used the fact that K is positive
because e to the minus K times a large
number is minus infinity and then here
plus 1 over K right minus a minus 1 over
2 let me write it the same way I did
before all right and that's just equal
to 0 plus 1 over K which is what we want
all right so this is the same
calculation just slightly abbreviated
yeah question
good right the question is what about
the case when the limit is infinity
i I'm distinguishing between something
existing and its limit being infinity
here whenever whenever I make a
discussion of limits I say a finite
limit or in this case it works for
infinite limits so in other words I when
I say exists I mean fine exists n is
finite all right so here when I say that
it converges and I say the limit exists
what I mean is that it's a finite number
and so that's indeed what I said here
the total area is finite and similarly
over here I might add however that there
is another part of this subject which
I'm skipping entirely which is a little
bit subtle which is the following if f
changes sign there can be some
cancellation and oscillation and then
sometimes the limit exists but the total
area if you counted at all positively is
actually still infinite and we're going
to avoid that case we're not going to
we're just going to treat these positive
cases so so don't worry about that for
now that's that's the next layer of
complexity which we're not addressing in
this class another question
this be okay on tests
the answer is absolutely yes I want to
encourage you to do this if you can
think about it correctly the subtle
point is just you have to plug in
infinity correctly namely you have to
realize that it only this only works if
K is positive this is the step where
you're plugging in infinity and I'm
letting you put this infinity up here as
an endpoint value so that's the that's
in fact that's exactly the theme right
the theme is dealing with infinity here
and I want you to be able to deal with
it that's that's my goal yes
okay so another question how is so let's
be sure here when the exhibit exists I
say it has to be finite it can be if
that means it's finite not infinite okay
the limit can be zero it can also be
negative one it can be anything it
doesn't have to be a positive number
all right other questions so we've had
our first example and now I just want to
add one one physical interpretation here
this is of example one if you like and
this is something that was on your
problem set remember that we talked
about the probability or the number if
you like the number of particles on
average that decay in some radioactive
substance say in time between zero and
some capital T all right and then that
would be this integral 0 to capital T
some total quantity times this integral
here this is the typical kind of
radioactive decay number that one gets
now in the limit so this is some number
of particles
if the substance is radioactive then in
the limit we have this which is equal to
the total number of particles and that's
a something that's going to be important
for normalizing and understanding you
know what how much does the whole
substance how many moles do we have of
this stuff what what is it and so this
is a number that it's going to come up
now I emphasize that this notion of T
going to infinity is just an
idealization we don't really believe
that we're going to wait forever for
this substance to decay nevertheless as
theorists we write down this quantity
and we use it all the time
furthermore there's a other good reasons
for using it in why physicists accept it
immediately even though it's not really
completely physically realistic ever to
let time go very very far into the
future and the reason is if you notice
this answer here look at how much
simpler this number is 1 over K then the
numbers that I got in the intermediate
stages here these are all ugly the
limits are simple and this is a theme
that I've been trying to emphasize all
semester namely that the infinitesimal
the things that you get when you do
differentiation are the easier formulas
the algebraic ones the things in the
process of getting to the limit are the
ugly ones these are the easy ones these
are the hard ones
so in fact infinity is basically easier
than any finite number and a lot of
appealing formulas come from those kinds
of calculations another question
question should answer be a well the
answer turns out to be a / K right which
means that when you set up your
arithmetic and you model this to a
collection of particles so you said it
should be a but that's because you said
you made an assumption which was that a
was the total number of particles but
that's just false right this is the
total number of particles so therefore
if you want to set it up you want to set
up so that this number is the total
number of particles all right and that's
how you set up a model is you do all the
calculations and you see what it's
coming out to be and that's why you need
to do this kind of calculation all right
okay
so the main thing is I mean you
shouldn't make assumptions about models
you have to follow what the calculations
tell you they don't they're not lying
all right okay
so now we cared this out there's one
other example which we talked about
earlier in the class and I just wanted
to mention it again it's probably the
most famous after this one namely the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of e to the minus x squared DX which
turns out amazingly to be able to be
evaluated it turns out to be the square
root of pi so this one is also great
this is the one the constant which
allows you to compute all kinds of
things in probability so this is a key
number and probability it basically is
the key to understanding things like
standard deviation and basically any
other thing in this in the subject of
probability it's also what's driving
these polls that tell you you know
within four percent accuracy we know
that people are going to vote this way
or that so in order to interpret all of
those
kinds of things you need to know this
number and this number was only
calculated numerically starting in the
1700s or so by people who well actually
by one guy whose name was de moivre who
was selling his services to various
royalty who were running lotteries in
those days they ran lotteries too and so
he wanted to he was able to tell them
what the chances were of the various
games and he worked out this number he
realized that this was the pattern
although he didn't know that it was the
square root of pi he knew it to
sufficient accuracy that he could tell
them the correct answer to how much
money their their lotteries would make
and of course we do this nowadays too in
all kinds of ways including slightly
more legit businesses like insurance
okay so all right so now I'm going to
give you some more examples and and the
other examples are much more close to
the edge between infinite and finite
this this distinction between
convergence and divergence and let me
just maybe I'll say one more word about
why we care about this very gross issue
of whether something is finite or
infinite when you're when you're talking
about something like this normal curve
here there's there's an issue there's an
issue of how far out you have to go
before you can ignore the rest so we're
going to ignore what's called the tail
here somehow you want to know that this
is negligible you won't know how
negligible it is and this is the job of
a mathematician is to know what finite
region you have to consider and which
one you're going to care actively
calculate numerically and then the rest
you're going to have to take care of by
some theoretical reasoning you're going
to have to know that these tails are
small enough that they don't matter in
your finite calculation
we care very much about the tails
because they're the only thing that the
Machine won't tell us that's the part
that we have to know and these tails are
also something which are discussed all
the time in financial mathematics
they're very worried about fat tails
that is unlikely events that
nevertheless happens sometimes and they
get burned fairly regularly with them as
they have recently with the mortgage
scandal so you know these things are
pretty serious and they really are
spending a lot of time on of course
there are lots of other practical issues
besides just the mathematics but you've
got to get the math right - all right so
we're going to now talk about some
borderline cases for these fat tails
just how fat do they have to be before
they become infinite and overwhelm the
central bump though we'll save this for
just a second and what I'm saving up
here is the borderline case which I'm
going to concentrate on which is this
moderate rate which is x2 powers here's
our our next example I guess we'll call
this example 3 it's the integral from 1
to infinity DX over X that's the power P
equals 1 and this turns out to be a
borderline case so it's worth carrying
out carefully now again I'm going to do
it by this by the slower method rather
than the shorthand method but ultimately
you can do it by the law of the short
method if you'd like I break it up into
a an integral that goes up to some large
number n I see that it's the logarithm
function is the antiderivative and so
what I get is log n minus log 1 which is
just 0 so this is just log in in any
case it tends to infinity as n goes to
infinity so the conclusion is since the
limit is infinite that this thing
diverges
now I'm going to do this systematically
now with all powers P to see what
happens I'll look at the integral sorry
I'm going to have to start at one here
one to infinity DX over X to the P power
and see what happens with these and
you'll see that P equals one as a
borderline when I do this calculation
this time I'm going to do the
calculation the hard way
but now you're going to have to think
and pay attention to see what it is that
I'm doing first of all I'm going to take
the antiderivative and that's X this is
X to the minus P so it's minus P plus 1
divided by minus P plus 1 that's the
antiderivative of the function X to the
1 over X to the P or X to the minus P
and then I have to evaluate that at 1
and infinity so now I'll write this down
but I'm going to be particularly careful
here I'll write it down it's it's
infinity to the minus P plus 1 over
minus P plus 1 minus so I plug in 1 here
so I get 1 over minus P plus 1 alright
so this is what I'm getting again what
you should be thinking here is this is a
very large number to this power now
there are two cases there are two cases
and they exactly split at P equals 1
when P equals 1 this number is 0 this
exponent is 0 and in fact this
expression doesn't make any sense
because the denominator is also 0 but
for all of the other values the
denominator makes sense but what's going
on is that this is infinite when this
exponent is infinity to a positive power
and it's 0 when it's infinity to a
negative power
all right so I'm going to say it here
and you must check this at home because
this is exactly what I'm going to ask
you about on the exam all right this is
it this type of thing maybe with a
specific value of P here when P is less
than 1 this thing is infinite on the
other hand when P is greater than 1 this
thing is zero so when P is greater than
1 this thing is zero it's just equal to
zero and so the answer is 1 over P minus
1 because that's this number minus the
quantity 1 over minus P plus 1 all right
this is a finite number here notice that
the answer would be weird if this thing
went away in the in the P less than 1
case then it would be a negative number
be very strange answer to this question
so in fact that's not what happens what
happens is that that the answer doesn't
make sense it's infinite so let me just
write this down again under here this is
a test in a particular case and here's
the conclusion ah no I'm sorry I think I
was going to write it over on this board
here
so the conclusion is that the integral
from 1 to infinity DX over X to the P
diverges if P is less than or equal to 1
and converges if P is greater than 1 and
in fact we can actually evaluate it it's
equal to 1 over P minus 1 it's got a
nice clean formula even all right now
let me remind you so I didn't spell the
word diverges right did I oh no that's
an R yes that's right
okay diverges if P is less than equal to
1 so really I needed both of these
arguments which are sitting above it in
order to do it because the second
argument all didn't work at all when P
was equal to 1 because the formula for
the antiderivative is wrong the formula
for the antiderivative is given by the
log function when P is equal to 1 so I
had to do this calculation too this is
the borderline case between P bigger
than 1 and P less than 1 when P was
bigger than 1 we got convergence we
could calculate the integral when P was
strictly less than 1 we got divergence
and we calculated the integral over
there and here in the borderline case we
got a logarithm and we also got
divergence so it failed at the edge now
this takes care of all the powers
all right now there are a number of
different things that one can deduce
from this and let me carry them out so
this is more or less the second thing
that you'll want to do and I'm going to
emphasize maybe one aspect of it I guess
we'll get rid of this but it's still the
issue that we're discussing here is
whether these this area is fat or thin
remind you of that so here's the next
idea something called limit comparison
limit comparison is what you're going to
use when instead of being able actually
to calculate the number you don't yet
know what the number is but you can make
in comparison to something whose
convergence properties you already
understand well here's the statement if
a function f is similar to a function
asymptotically the same as a function G
as X goes to infinity I'll remind you
what that means in a second then the
integral starting at some point out to
infinity of f of X DX and the other one
convergent divergent the same time so
both either either sorry either let's
try it the other way either both either
both converge or both diverge they
behave exactly the same way in terms of
whether they're infinite or not
and let me remind you what this what
this tilde means this thing means that f
of X divided by G of X tends to one so
if you have a couple of functions like
that then their behavior is the same
this is more or less obvious it's just
because far enough out this is for large
a if you like we're not paying any
attention to what happens it just has to
do with the tail and after a while f of
X and G of X are comparable to each
other so their integrals are comparable
to each other all right so let's just do
a couple of examples here if you take
the integral from zero to infinity DX
over the square root of x squared plus
10 then I claim that the square root of
x squared plus ten resembles the square
root of x squared which is just X so
this thing is going to be like so now
I'm going to have to do one thing to you
here which is I'm going to change this
to one to infinity DX over X and the
reason is that this x equals zero is
extraneous it doesn't have anything to
do with what's going on with this
problem
this guy here the piece of it from so so
we're going to ignore the part integral
from 0 to 1 DX over square root of x
squared plus 10 which is finite anyway
and unimportant whereas unfortunately
the integral of DX will have a
singularity at x equals zero so we can't
make the comparison there alright anyway
this one is infinite so this is
divergent
all right using using what I what I knew
from before all right yeah the question
is what did why did we switch from zero
to one so I'm going to I'm going to say
a little bit more about that later but
let me just make it a warning here which
is that this guy here is infinite for
other reasons unrelated reasons the
comparison that we are trying to make is
with the tail as X goes to infinity so
another way of saying this is that I
should stick an a here and an a here and
get stay away from zero so say say a
equals 1 if I make these both 1 that
would be ok if I make them both too that
would be okay if I make them both a
hundred that would be okay
so let's leave it as a hundred right now
and it's acceptable I want you to stay
away from the origin here because that's
another bad point and just talk about
what's happening with the tail all right
so this is a tail and I also had a
different name for it up top which is
emphasizing this which is limit
comparison it's only what's happening at
the very end of the picture that we're
interested in so again this is as X goes
to infinity that's the limit we're
talking about the limiting behavior and
we try not to pay attention to what's
happening for small values of X
so if I if I to be consistent if I'm
going to do it up to 100 I'm ignoring
what's happening up to the first hundred
values all right in any case this guy
diverged and let me give you another
example this one you could have computed
this one you could have computed right
because it's it's a quadratic square
root of quadratic so there's a trig
substitution that evaluates this one the
the advantage of this limit comparison
method is it makes no difference whether
you can compute the thing or not you can
still decide whether it's finite or
infinite fairly easily so let me give
you an example of that so here we have
another example we'll take the integral
DX square root of x cubed plus three
let's say for the sake of argument all
right from zero to infinity
let's let's let's leave off let's make a
10 to infinity whatever all right now
this one is problematic for you you're
not going to be able to evaluate it I
promise so on the other hand 1 over the
square root of x cubed plus 3 is similar
to 1 over the square root of x cubed
which is 1 over x to the three-halves so
this thing is going to resemble this
integral here
which is convergent according to our
rule all right so those are the more or
less the main ingredients let me just
mention one other integral which was the
one that we had over here this one here
if you if you look at this integral of
course we can compute it so we know the
area is finite but the way that you
would actually carry this out if you
just if you didn't know the number and
you wanted to check that this integral
were finite then you would make the
following comparison this one is not so
difficult first of all you would write
it as twice the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus x squared DX
so we are going to this is a new example
here so and we're just checking for
convergence only not evaluation and now
I'm going to make a comparison here
rather than a limit comparison I'm
actually just going to make an ordinary
comparison that's because this thing
vanishes so fast it's so favorable that
we can only put something on top of it
we can't get something underneath it
that exactly balances with it in other
words this wiggle was something which
had the same growth rate as the function
involved this thing just vanishes
incredibly fast it's great it's too good
for us for this comparison so instead
what I'm going to make is the following
comparison each of the minus x squared
is less than or equal to e to the minus
X at least for X bigger than or equal to
1 right when X is bigger than or equal
to 1 then x squared is bigger than or
equal to X and so minus x squared is
less than minus X and so e to the minus
x squared is less than this this is
the reasoning involved and so what we
have here is two pieces we have two the
integral from zero to one of e to the
minus x squared that's just a finite
part and then we have this other part
which I'm going to replace with the e to
the minus X here two times one to
infinity e to the minus X DX all right
so so I'm this is if you like this is
ordinary comparison of integrals it's
something that we did way at the
beginning of the class or much earlier
on when we were dealing with integrals
which is that if you have a larger
integrand then the integral is gets
larger so we've replaced the inner we've
got the same integrand on 0 to 1 and
then we have a larger integrand on so
this one is larger integrand over here
and this one we know is finite all right
this one is a convergent integral so the
whole business is convergent so this is
but of course we replace it by a much
larger thing so we're not getting the
right number out of this we're just
showing that it converges
all right so these are the the main
ingredients as I say once the thing gets
really really fast decaying it's
relatively straightforward but it's
there's lots of room to show that it
converges all right now there's one last
item of business here which I have to
promise you which is which is a which I
promised you which had to do with
dealing with this with this bottom piece
here okay so I have to deal with what
happens when there's this when there's a
singularity this is known as an improper
integral of the second type and the idea
of these examples is the following you
might have something like this something
like this or something like this all
right these are typical sorts of
examples and before actually describing
what happens I just want to mention so
first of all the key point here is you
can just calculate these things and plug
in zero and it works and you'll get the
right answer
all right so you'll determine you'll
figure out that it turns out that this
one will converge this one will diverge
and this one will diverge that's what
will turn out to happen however I want
to warn you that you that you can fool
yourself and so let me give you a
slightly different example let's
consider this integral here all right
the integral from minus 1 to 1
DX over x squared if you carry out this
integral without thinking what will
happen is you'll get the antiderivative
which is minus X to the minus 1
evaluated at minus 1 and 1 and you plug
it in ok and what do you get you get
minus 1 1 to the power minus 1 - OH -
minus 1 2 minus 1 a lot of minus ones in
this problem ok so that's minus 1 and
this one if you work it all out as I
sometimes don't get the signs where I
put up but at this time I really paid
attention all right it's minus 1 I'm
telling you that's what it is all right
so that comes out to be minus 2 now this
is ridiculous this function here this
function here is looks like this ok it's
positive right 1 over x squared is
positive how exactly is it that the area
between minus 1 and 1 came out to be a
negative number
all right that can't be there was
clearly something wrong with this and
this is the kind of thing that you'll
get regularly if you don't pay attention
to convergence of integrals so what's
going on here is actually that this area
in here is infinite and this calculation
that I made is nonsense all right so it
doesn't work this is wrong because it's
divergent actually when you get to
imaginary numbers it'll turn out that
there's a way of rescuing it but that's
but still it means something totally
different when that integral is thought
to be minus 2 so what I want you to do
here so I think we'll have to finish
this up very briefly next time we'll do
these three calculations and you'll
see that these two guys are diverging
divergent and this one converges and
we'll do that next time